In the central dogma, the process by which the DNA
is being turned into RNA is called transcription.
Once you've made the messenger RNA, when it turned
into proteins, that process is called translation.
Proteins are complex polymer. The repeating
sub-units that are found in proteins are called
amino acids and there are essentially 20 different
kinds of amino acids. The amino acids have an
amine part of the molecule, and they have an acid
part of the molecule, and a variable side chain.
The variable side chain can consist of acidic
residues, basic residues, hydrophobic residues.
Based on whether they're charged, like
the acids or the bases, or uncharged,
or hydrophobic or hydrophilic, the different
amino acids, has slightly different properties.
Each amino acid can hooked together by the amino,
and the acid part of it and form a long chain.
The side chains kind of hanging off of the
side. The polypeptide formed can then fold up,
sort of like a string of spaghetti, because
the polymer part of the chain is very flexible.
However, what they like to do is fold up into
a ball, so that the hydrophobic parts of the
molecule will hide away from the water and the
hydrophilic parts will interact with the water.
Some of the reactive parts, the acids and
the bases, are in pockets on the surface.
These typically form what are
called the active sites of enzymes.
And because those are reactive acids
and bases, they can catalyze reactions.
For example, when you eat sugar, that
goes through a process called glycolysis,
which involves a series of proteins that
are folded up into a particular shape,
such that they recognize glucose. The sugar
binds to the enzyme, which is a protein,
in what is called a lock and key mechanism.
It fits in a very precise way, such that
certain chemical moieties are in close contact
with certain amino acids that are reactive,
typically acids or bases. That allows the
enzyme to do a chemical reaction on the sugar,
so the sugar begins to be broken
down in a series of steps.
About 15 steps that break down the sugar, allow
your body to use the pieces of the sugar to make
ATP that fuel chemical reaction of many biological
processes in the body. Some part of the sugar will
be used to make the amino acids that went into
the protein, and some part will be sued to make
the nucleotides that go together to make the RNA
and to make the DNA, in the most efficient way.
Not all protein are enzymes. Some proteins have
a particular shape that lets them fit together,
and this forms the cytoskeleton, which
gives your cells the shape that they have
and allows your cells to fit together
to give your body the shape that it has.
It's the three dimensional shape of the proteins
that allows them to carry out their functions,
whether it's structural, or
metabolic, or energy conservation,
or information processing. That shape is caused
by the amino acids and their chemical properties.
But the trick that makes this work, they have
to be hooked together in the proper order,
one after another. So, a typical protein may have
from 100 to maybe 1000 different amino acids.
Where is that order of amino acids come from?
It comes from the RNA, and the RNA gets that
from the DNA. So what the DNA code does is
that the bases in the DNA go together to tell
the ribosome through the action of the messenger
RNA, what order to hook the amino acids together.
This is called the genetic code. So, in your
DNA, you've learned there are four bases, A,
T, G, and C. And the order at which those
are found in the DNA, three at a time.
So, the order of amino acids that are put
together in the protein by the ribosome,